- Let’s begin with the mantra.
- Mak one gnag—
- Making it to the Super Bowl WAS an accomplishment.
- I definitely liked winning the Super Bowl
more than losing it.
- All in favor of kicking Pat out of the group?
- Second order of business…
PROJECT XO.
Our coaches can’t scout a real QB to replace us
if they are too busy scouting a fake QB.
- I really don’t think we’re gonna be replaced.
- Finally, another Kirk Cousins.
- FINE!
It’s time for fake QB prospect
BROCK MOXIE.
- We’re gonna need to think young and hip,
so I enlisted—
- DREW LOCK IN THE HIZZY.
[Air horn]
OOH.
This is my Madden station/
state-of-the-art draft sim.
Really banking on y'all to save your boy’s job.
- Step one:
Get the word out.
- You know, I’m hearing a lot of good things
about this Brock Moxie.
- I don’t trust Justin Fields’ background.
You know,
Ohio State.
- You know, Brock Moxie went to
North Hawaii Christian Military.
That place is a dang QB factory.
- Wow.
- Step two:
hype videos.
- Well, there’s almost no tape on Trey Lance,
so you know I love him.
- Yeah, you know who there’s even less tape on?
- Bro, you look great,
but we’re not supposed to see your face.
- Step 3:
Let the media do its thing.
- Connor,
Brock Moxie:
Is the hype real?
- Look, Lefkoe,
my player comp is Patrick Mahomes
mixed with the trickster god Loki.
- My sources are saying that
every other QB besides Brock Moxie
is a low-class idiot who hates football.
- To keeping our jobs!
- WHOOPS.
- [Computer voice:] Creating Brock Moxie.
- WHAT’S HAPPENING?!
- Uh-oh, that’s right.
Madden now lets you
physically create a character.
- Hello, I’m rookie Brock Moxie,
and I don’t even have a baby voice.
- [Gasping]
- KILL, KILL, KILL.
- BUT THINGS WORK OUT FOR ME.
I’M HOT.
- HURRY!
HE RUNS A 4.2 40.
- [Cam Newton:] Oh, God,
he escaped the pocket.
- Yeah, man, I just think,
“Who would I want to work
in a coal mine with?”
and I draft that guy, man.
- Prepare to have a sophomore slump…
IN HELL.
- WATCH OUT.
- OFFENSIVE LINEMAN OUT OF OREGON
- Huh?
What’s this?
- MUST. START. QUARTERBACK. CONTROVERSY.
- GEE GAD!
PLEASE!
THINK OF ALL THE CHILDREN WITH
THEIR ANDY DALTON BEARS JERSEYS!